[Music]
hi
my name is emily reader and today i'm
here to talk about how to design
packages
for your organization think about the
last time that you joined a new
organization
there was so much you needed to learn
before you could start contributing
remember the frustration when you
couldn't figure out how to access data
the lost hours trying to answer the
wrong question before you built up your
intuition
and the awkwardness of figuring out team
norms through trial and error
when we join a new organization we must
learn these things
only once before we can hit the ground
running however
the off-the-shelf tools that we use
can't preserve this context
every day is like their first day at
work unlike
open source packages internal packages
can embrace institutional knowledge
more like a colleague in two important
ways first and foremost
they can aim to solve far more domain
specific and concrete problems
than open source packages second
although narrower in
the scope of the defined problem their
insight into our organization
allows them to be more holistic in the
solutions they propose
by internalizing more steps of the
necessary workflow to answer that
question
covering areas like pulling data and
communicating with colleagues
because of these two factors internal
packages
can add a lot of value by interfacing
internal utilities
streamlining the analysis process and
empowering data scientists to create
high quality results
but more than the tasks they can do
today
i want to talk about how to design such
internal packages
to be as rich in context as possible
to do this i like to think about the
popular jobs to be done framework for
product development
this asserts that we hire a product to
do a job that helps us make
progress towards the goal and to me
it's that notion of progress and truly
knowing the ins and outs of what sort of
progress our users need to make
that sets internal packages apart
additionally
these jobs can have functional social
and emotional aspects
for the rest of this discussion i'll
tweak this framework
just slightly let's build a team of
packages
to do the jobs that help our org answer
impactful questions
with efficient workflows so what sort of
teammate should our packages be
let's meet a few first i'd like to
introduce you to the it guy
think of a helpful or friendly itr
devops colleague that you may know
they're fantastic at handling the quirks
of infrastructure
and abstracting away all the sorts of
things that data scientists don't want
to spend their time thinking about
like proxies connections servers etc
in that abstraction process they also
take on additional responsibilities
to promote good practices like data
security and credential management
ideally they can save us a lot of time
and frustration in navigating
organization-specific roadblocks
that no amount of searching on stack
overflow can help
so how can we encode these
characteristics in a package
providing utility functions can help
achieve that same type of abstraction
and in these functions we can take an
opinionated stance
and craft helpful error messages let's
take a look at an example
suppose we want to write a function to
connect ourselves to a database
first we might start out with a rather
boilerplate piece of code
using the dbi package we take in the
username and password
hardcode the driver name server location
port
and return the connection object now
let's suppose our organization has
strict rules against putting
secure credentials in plain text as well
they should
in an open source package i wouldn't
presume to force users hands
to use one specific system setup however
in this case
we can make strong assumptions based on
our knowledge
of an organization's rules and norms
and this sort of function can be great
leverage to incentivize users
to do the right thing like storing their
credentials and environment variables
because it's the only way they can get
the function to work
of course that's only helpful if we
provide descriptive error messages when
the user does not have their credentials
set up this way
otherwise they'll get an error that
dbpass is missing
find nothing useful online to help them
troubleshoot since this is an internal
choice that we made
so we can enhance this function with an
extremely custom and prescriptive error
message
explaining what went right wrong and
either how to fix it
or where we can get more information
of course even better than explaining
errors is preventing them from occurring
at all
we might also know at our specific
organization that non-alphanumeric
characters
are required in passwords and the
dbconnect doesn't natively encode these
correctly
when passing them to the database
instead of troubling the user and
telling them how to pick their password
we can instead handle this silently
inside of the function
however strong opinions and complete
independence
don't always make a great colleague
other times
we might want someone more like a junior
analyst they know a good bit about the
organization
and we can trust them to execute
calculations correctly
and make reasonable assumptions at the
same time
we want them to be responsive to our
feedback and willing to try things out
in more ways than one
so how can we capture these jobs in an
internal package
we can build in productive yet
responsive functions
with default arguments reserved keywords
and the ellipsis
to illustrate imagine a basic
visualization function
that reacts ggplot2 code but allows
users to input
their preferred x y and grouping
variables to draw cohort curves
this function is fine but we can
probably draw on institutional knowledge
to push our junior analyst to be a
little bit more proactive
if we relied on the same opinionated
design as the it guy
we might consider hard coding some of
the variables inside of the function
here though that isn't a great approach
it isn't the junior analyst's job to
give edux
we might know what the desired x-axis
will be 80 of the time
but hard coding here is too strong of an
assumption and decreases the usefulness
of the function for that other 20
percent
instead we can put our best guess 80
right names
as the default arguments in the function
header ordered by decreasing likelihood
of the need to override this means when
users do not provide their own value
a default is used that's the junior
analyst's best guess
but users retain complete control to
change it
as they see fed this approach becomes
even more powerful
if we can abstract out a small set of
incredibly common
frequently occurring assumed variable
names or other values
we can define and document this set of
keywords or
special variable names that span all of
our internal packages
if these are well known and well
documented users will get into the habit
of shaping their data so it plays nice
with the package ecosystem
and saves a lot of manual typing this
type of incentive
to standardize file names can have other
convenient consequences
in making data extracts more shareable
and
code more readable finally one other
nice trick in making our functions
responsive to feedback
is the ellipsis or passing the dots this
allows users to provide any number of
arbitrary additional arguments
beyond what was specified by the
developer and
plugs them in at a designated place in
the function body
this way users can extend functions
based on needs
that the developer could not have
anticipated like customizing the color
size and line type
so far we've mostly focused on that
first dimension
making our package teammates targeted to
solving
specific internal problems but there's
just as much value in that second
dimension
using internal packages is a way to ship
not just calculations
but workflows and to share an
understanding of how the broader
organization operates
to illustrate this consider our intrepid
tech lead
we value this type of teammate because
they can draw from a breadth of past
experience and institutional knowledge
to help you weigh trade-offs learn from
collected wisdom
inspire you to do your best work so
that's a pretty tall order to put in a
package but conscientious use of
vignettes and templates
can help us towards this goal vignettes
often help introduce basic functionality
of a package with a toy example
as found in the decliner vignette or
less commonly
they may discuss the statistical method
that's implemented
as done in the survival package
vignettes of an internal art package can
do
more diverse and numerous jobs these
vignettes can accumulate the hard-won
experience experience
and domain knowledge like an experienced
tech leads photographic memory
and they hand deliver these insights to
anyone currently working
on a related analysis just as a few
examples
you consider how you can consider having
completely code-free vignettes
that conceptually introduce you to a
common problem that your package
solves explain the workflow and key
questions
you should be asking yourself along the
way and even potentially get into
procedural weeds
like what you need to do to add features
or deploy a model
then after aligning with your users on a
conceptual framework you may introduce
the package's functionality and explain
how those two overlap when your package
contains functions for many different
ways to do a task
you can also compare pros and cons and
explain different situations where
different ones have proven
more or less effective finally vignettes
can also include lessons learned
reflections from past users and
references to past examples
to help analysts learn about similar
projects
in fact all of that context may be so
helpful
even to people that are not direct users
of your package
they may want to seek this mentorship in
this case
you can use the package down package to
automatically create a package website
to share these vignettes with anyone who
needs to learn more
about a specific problem space with
single function call
your package can share its wisdom more
broadly
and unlike their human counterparts the
packaged check lead
can always find time for another meeting
similar to vignettes embedded templates
take on a more important
and distinctive role for internal
packages
in open source packages our markdown
templates provide a pre-populated file
instead of the default this is most
commonly used to demonstrate proper
formatting syntax
for example the flux dashboard package
uses a template to show users how to set
up the yaml metadata
and section headers instead
internal packages can use templates to
coach users through workflows because
they understand the problems users are
facing
and the progress they hope to achieve
internal packages
can mentor users and structure their
work in two different ways
process walkthroughs can serve as
interactive notebooks
that coach users through common analyses
as an example if a type of analysis
requires manual data cleaning and
duration a template notebook
can guide users to ask the right
questions of their data and generate
common views they need to analyze
we can also include full end-to-end
analysis outlines which include
placeholder text
commentary and code if the type of
analysis that a package supports
usually results in a specific type of
report
similarly our package can include a
project template
not just in our markdown template these
templates can predefine
a standard file structure and a
boilerplate set of files
for a new project to give users a
helping hand and drive the kind of
consistency across projects
that any tech lead dreams of when doing
a code review
speaking of collaboration brings us to
the last teammate whose traits we want
our package to evoke
the project manager one of the biggest
differences
between task doing versus problem
solving packages
is understanding the whole workflow and
helping coordinate the project
across different components when writing
open source packages
we rightly assume that our intended
audience is our users
but on a true cross-functional internal
team not everyone will be
so we can intentionally modularize the
workflow and think about how to augment
our studio's ide
to make sure our tools work well with
all of our colleagues
one way to do this is with modularizing
the parts of the workflow that really do
or do not require our code for example
in the templates we just discussed we
could actually make separate template
components
for the parts that require our code and
for the parts that are just
english text and commentary the
commentary files
can be plain vanilla markdown files that
any collaborator could edit without even
having to have r
installed and the main markdown can pull
in this plain text output
using trial documents this approach is
now made even easier with advances in
the rstudio ide
the visual markdown editor provides a
great graphical user interface
to support word processing in markdown
for those plain
text narrative documents that we just
discussed
we can also use our studio add-ins to
extend the r studio interface
and ship interactive widgets in our
internal packages
to illustrate i've shown the
point-and-click plot coding assistant
from the open source squis package
add-ins require more investment up front
but they're much easier to maintain
than a full application and they can
help convert teammates to our users
besides a good project manager is
willing to go that extra mile to support
13.
now speaking of collaboration we've
talked about what can make an individual
package
a good teammate another major
opportunity
when building a suite of internal tools
is that we have
we can think about how multiple packages
on our team can best work together
we want teammates that are clear
communicators have defined
responsibilities
and keep their promises
we can help packages feed these sorts of
good teammates
with naming conventions clearly defined
scopes
and careful attention to dependencies
and testing
clear function naming conventions
inconsistent method signatures
help packages effectively communicate
with both package
and human collaborators internally
we can give our suite of internal
packages a richer
language by defining a consistent set of
prefixes
through name stubs that indicate how
each function is to be used
one approach i like is that each
function prefix can denote the type of
object that that function will return
for example using biz prefixes for
functions that return ggplot2 objects
this way past experience working with
one internal package
seamlessly translates to the next
another aspect of good team
communication is having clearly defined
roles and responsibilities
again since we own our whole internal
stack of packages
we have more freedom and how we can
choose to divide up functionality
and responsibilities across funk
packages
take for example the data science
workflow as described in the rf data
science book
open source packages inevitably have
overlapping functionality
which forces users to compare
alternatives and decide which is best
internally we can use some amount of
central planning
to ensure each package teammate has a
clearly defined role
whether that be to provide a horizontal
utility or to enable progress
on a specific work stream and
just like one team want to work well
with another that central planning can
include
curation and promotion of open source
tools
along with our internal ones after all
no one team can do it
all alone when assigning these rules to
our team of packages
we should be considering how to manage
the dependencies between them
when different functionality needs to be
shared across packages
packages often have direct dependencies
where a function in one package
calls function in another this is not
necessarily bad
but especially with internal packages
which might sometimes have a shorter
shelf life
and fewer developers this can sometimes
create a domino effect
if one package is deprecated or decides
to retire or take a vacation
we don't want the rest of our ecosystem
affected
alternatively we can use the fact that
both packages
a and b are under our control to see if
we can eliminate the explicit dependency
by promoting a clean handoff we can see
if a function
in a can produce an output that b can
consume instead of calling a's function
directly
additionally because we own the full
stack we may also consider
if there are shared needs in a and b
that should be extracted into a common
building block package c
for instance a set of common
visualization function primitives
this way we at least have a clear
hierarchy of dependencies
instead of a spider web and can identify
a small number of truly essential ones
regardless of the type of dependencies
we end up with we can use
tests to make sure our packages are
reliable teammates
who do what they're they promised
typically
if i write package b that depends on
package a
i can only control package fees tests so
i could write tests to see if a
continues to perform
as b is expecting this is a good
safeguard
but it means that we will only detect
problems after they've already been
introduced in a
there's nothing in place to actually
stop package a from getting distracted
in the first place instead we prefer
that both a and b be conscientious of
the promises they've made
and stay committed to working towards
their shared goal
we can formalize that shared vision with
integration tests
that is we can add tests to both the
upstream and the downstream packages
to ensure they continue to check in with
each other and inquire if any of the
changes they're planning
could be disruptive now just imagine
having such rigorous
and ongoing communication and
prioritization with your own teammates
in summary we all know the joy of
working with a great team
and given that you're here right now i
suspect you know the pleasure of
cracking open a new art package
by taking advantage of the unique
opportunities of designing internal
packages
we can achieve the best of both worlds
we can share the fun of working with
good tools
with the teammates we care about and we
can elevate those tools
to full-fledged teammates by giving them
the skills they need to succeed
thank you
you